.
Thank you.
Okay, it being 11 o'clock, I will call the work session on House Bill 1235 to order.
I don't have a lot of people who are interested in speaking to this bill is pretty straightforward.
It in essence increases the claimant compensation from 40 to $50,000.
It has an indeterminable estimated increase spending and it takes effect July 1, 2024.
Well do we have a motion?
Yes, Mr.
Chairman.
I can make a motion of ought to pass and I can speak to that briefly.
Okay.
Please.
Thank you.
Well, I would be interested in knowing more about the bill, but certainly it seems like an increase that is reasonable for those.
Are you here for 1235?
No.
Okay.
For those who are victims of certain crimes that are laid out in section 21 hyphen M colon 8 hyphen little h.
If there is anyone here that could answer just a couple of questions that would be great, but otherwise I don't see a problem with the bill moving forward.
What are your questions?
Just to be on the record with the questions.
Okay.
For example, when was the last time there was an increase?
And then how often is this fund distributed?
Well, good questions.
Maybe we'll get an answer at some point.
Okay, so we have a motion to OTP.
Do we have a second?
I'll second.
Seconded by Representative Griffin.
By all means.
Just the victims front, I think, is fine.
I'm just not sure that I concur with the FRM victims in the second part of this bill.
They're included in the same place.
It kind of puts me in conflict.
I fully support the thought that victims of any crime somehow should be compensated but from there.
And I just don't know that I believe that the way that the state is being held liable has ever occurred before, nor do I believe that it's correct.
I really don't believe that.
And spent a lot of time on this.
This bill was before us, each biennium for a while.
And to a person that was a victim that testified, most of them, not to persons, but most of them indicated that the people that perpetrated this crime were just good people and things were sour, and that's not true.
I've been the victim of not this amount of this type, but being shazammed by illegal people, people that are doing political acts.
Within my business, there was fraud perpetrated on me, and I didn't hold the state viable or the government viable.
During the collapse of the SNL loans, because of the type of business I had, I lost a boatload of money because of that.
But I couldn't hold the state or the federal government liable for the losses that I had.
And actually that was a lack of oversight.
You've got to turn your mic on.
That was a lack of oversight by a plethora of governmental agencies.
And I would have liked to recover the thousands I lost.
And in fact, I did, but I had to do other things to make that happen.
So I feel bad for the people, always have.
But I just don't agree that this is a liability that the state should undertake.
And we're using taxpayer money, just think about this, we're using taxpayer money to compensate for people that were taken in by nothing less than a Ponzi scheme, and the thought that it was the liability of the states, and that goes against every principle that I've learned about, how government operates and what happens and liabilities.
I can't support this.
Well, I think that's already been done.
That was in HB 2.
What this does is it says if there's any unclaimed funds, it goes into the Victims Assistance Fund.
So the ship you're talking about has sailed.
What this does is it says...
I have to go on it.
Okay.
What this says is if there are any funds left over they go into this victims fund that's all this does is direct any leftovers unclean okay all right certainly in any other comments tolerance, Mr.
Peter.
Certainly.
Any other comments?
Okay, well, I guess would the clerk call the roll?
Okay, the motion is ought to pass.
If you're in favor, you'll vote in the affirmative.
The motion is ought to pass.
If not, you'll vote in the negative.
That being said, okay, Mr.
Chairman.
Yes.
Vice Chairman Griffin.
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Mooney.
Yes.
Richard Hatch is absent.
Okay.
And Representative Wallace is absent.
So the vote is 4 to 1 in favor.
Okay.
So we will report to finance.
The vote is 4 to 1.
Ought to pass.
And with that, we conclude the work session for 1235.
Okay, got it.
Now we will be back at 1 o'clock.
35.
Now we will be back at 1 o'clock and just for the committee's information Monday we have five bills and We're gonna they're all scheduled for 10 So that we're gonna just get into them and get them all done.
This Monday?
Next Monday.
Oh, my God.
No, we've got to wait until this afternoon.
Yeah, one is at one and one is at two.
Yeah, this is where I learned not to schedule.
I can read some copies.
When we get those copies from Janet.
Sure.
Yeah.
Well, that's good.
I will go.
Okay.
Thanks.
One, two, three.
Is that Monday the 14th?
Yes.
Hi.
Oh.
Yes.
Good luck.
Joel, I have to call you back.
I'm in a committee meeting.
Starting off at 10?
10.
Good.
Someone took my parking space from what burned.
Someone took my apartment in this case from Mount Vernon.
Hello.
Who hears from Mount Vernon, I wonder?
I don't know.
I have the deputy speaker taking my spot.
You should know better.
Are we still live?
We are still live.
Okay.
Oops.
It's okay.
So we'll be back.
It's still on.
Well, we will reconvene at 1 o'clock.
The first one was an easy vote.
Okay.
The answer to your question is 1997.
That was the last time this section involved.
Okay.
Thank you.
The section is 1997.
That was the last time this section was all updated.
Thank you.
What it does, it moves quite a bit of money from fiscal 2024 to 2023.
So as a work session, if anybody has any comments they'd like to make about this bill, I'd invite them to come forward and give us their thoughts.
Please, if you'd state your name for the record, it'd be helpful.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
13 years.
I'm here today in support of House Bill 1535, which was granted COVID to retirees.
Excuse, please.
Could you turn on your mic and can I have the correct spelling of your last name?
Sure.
It's B-E-A-U-D-R-Y.
I did send a copy of this and I'm not sure because I did ask one of the reps and he didn't get it, but I did send a copy of my testimony to everybody through email.
Well, if you wouldn't mind, if you could leave that one with the clerk.
I can do that.
Okay, thank you.
For those of you who may not know the history of the granting of COLAs, here's a little background.
Prior to the establishment of the special account in 1983, the fund to fund cost of living adjustments, the cost of living COLA was granted by the legislature and funded through the general fund from 1967 to 1983.
From 1983 to 2012, annual COLAs were granted based on the availability to fund them through the special account.
The COLA amount ranged from 1% to 5% based on the CPIU and funds available in the members group account.
In 2007, House Bill 653 changed the funding trigger as of June 30, 2007 for the special account and retained $204 million in the corpus of the fund that would have gone into the special account.
2008 House Bill 1645 transferred $250 million from the special account to the corpus of the fund.
2011 House Bill 2 transferred $167 million from the special account to the corpus of the fund 2011 house bill 2 transferred 167 million from the special account to the corpus of the fund 2012 house bill 1483 eliminated the language for the special account and retained 16 million dollars that was transferred from the special account to the corpus of the fund the elimination of the special of the special account and transfer of $637 million from the special account to the corpus of the fund.
The elimination of the special account and transfer of $637 million from the special account to the corpus of the fund have precluded any further COLAs from being granted to New Hampshire retirement system retirees unless enabling legislation is enacted.
Retirees have received one COLA since July 1 of 2010.
It was a 1.5% cost of living increase based upon the retirees' first $50,000.
Over the last decade, family premiums for employer-sponsored health insurance coverage has jumped 47%, according to the report of the Kaiser Family Foundation.
Over that same time period, the cost of living has gone up 23 percent while retirees received just a one and a half percent increase.
I want to remind you that the average retiree pension is $21,300 a year.
93 percent of the retirees make less than $50,000 a year and 64 percent of the retirees make less than $50,000 a year, and 64% of the retirees make less than $25,000 a year.
Very simple math will show you that in a matter of a few years without COLA adjustments, pensioners will be forced on some form of social services because our pensions will be devoured by inflation.
I also want to remind you that Group 2 doesn't receive Social Security.
The pension is our main income once we retire.
There's a report developed through NASRA on cost of living adjustments that shows how inflation impacts the purchase power.
A $25,000 pension falls to $16,690, 67% of its original value over a 20-year period with no cost of living adjustment based on a 2% inflation factor.
The natural brief also shows that New Hampshire is an anomaly.
Most states provide their retirees with a cost of living adjustment.
The state of Maine, for example, who came to testify at the request of the decennial committee stated that they offer a 2.5% COLA to their retirees.
Massachusetts offers a ad hoc COLA typically based on the CPIU up to 3% applied to the first $13,000 benefit.
Vermont offers an automatic cola based on the CPIU up to 5% compounded.
Over the last several years the legislature has arbitrarily taken funds away from the retired workers that would have paid for colas and health care subsidies By changing dates and when excess earnings were reported and the elimination of the special account, some $637 million dedicated to retirees was confiscated for no justifiable reason other than to lower the employer's contribution on the backs of the retirees.
Granting a reasonable call-off for retirees will greatly reduce the impact inflation has incurred over the last decade.
I ask that you please support our retired workers and vote for House Bill 1535.
Thank you, and I will answer any questions.
Any questions?
Representative Leshman.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thanks for taking my question.
Is there any reason this legislation wasn't filed last year as far as the budget year, which would have made it probably easier to try to find the funds versus the second part of the session?
The only reason I could say, I haven't talked to 400 legislators, but my understanding is the COLA that was granted in 2019, the way it was granted, it didn't really start until July of 2020.
And I didn't receive my cost of living until January of 2021 because it was based on the month you retired.
So I retired in January, so I didn't get my one and a half percent until January of 2021.
So it was really 11 and a half years before I received a cost of living raise.
So I think that they didn't because they were still implementing the one that was that was put in in 2019.
They didn't want to go with another coal.
And I think there was some concern about funding it.
But that's only my opinion.
What I think.
Further question?
Thanks, Mr.
Chairman.
I guess the underlying financial concern that I have is on the fiscal note that the impact to all the political subdivisions, you know, towns and cities could be $135 million.
Do you have any indication that towns and cities are okay with this legislation?
Well, as a retired school board member for 20 years in the city of Manchester, I can tell you with the downshifting that has occurred over the last decade, I would probably say no, but that shouldn't preclude retirees getting a cost of living to try to keep them par with other people.
And like I said, I'll keep repeating myself on group two.
That's our main income.
So if we don't get cost of living raises, most of us don't get Social Security.
So at least Group 1 can fall back on their Social Security.
And they got 5.9 percent, I think it was this year, with Group 2.
I mean, if we don't get our Kohler and our pension, we really don't get anything.
Thanks.
Thanks, Mr.
Chairman.
Certainly.
Other questions from the committee?
Okay, seeing none, thank you very much.
Thank you.
I'll hand this to the clerk, if you don't mind.
Thank you very much.
You're welcome.
Anyone else?
Yes, sir.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
For the record, my name is Marty Carlin, representing the New Hampshire Retirement System.
NHRS doesn't have a position on the bill, but I came up to answer any questions you may have.
The hand that I presented you is an updated version of what we did for House eDNA when this bill was introduced with that committee earlier this year.
Excuse me, could you spell your last name?
I don't see it on your handout.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, K-A-R-L-O-N as in Nancy.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
So it's just some basic information on the history of coal.
It's a little bit less extensive than Mr.
Beaudry had provided and it also updates the financial considerations to the the new fiscal note which is a one-time permanent cola terminally funded ie paid up front which is 79 million a representative Leishman asked mr.
Beaudry about the 135 million5 million for the communities.
The original bill, before it was amended, had a recurring Kohler every year, granted the discretion of the Board of Trustees, and that was much pricier long-term than this bill.
This is a one-time permanent increase, and the amendment that came out of ED& would have the state front the money for this Kohler up front, so there wouldn't be any impact on municipal contributions under the bill as presented to the committee.
The fiscal note that came with the bill that we should disregard.
Which one?
I'll turn to Mr.
Hoffman.
I saw the new one online today.
We have the new one, but I'm just saying, the new one doesn't have municipalities and, it just has the state.
Yeah, that's the correct one.
Okay.
It's dated March 7th.
So just to clarify that.
So again, Mr.
Beaudry kind of covered the history of COLAs.
If there's any questions about the mechanics or how the cost estimate was developed by the actuary, I'd be glad to answer them.
So this fiscal note has 79,100,000 in current fiscal year.
Yes.
I'm just clarifying.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a lot of money.
Yeah.
As Mr.
Baudry mentioned, there was a funding mechanism.
It was a flawed funding mechanism called the special account.
And COLAs back in the 90s and 2000s were pre-funded in this way.
It's called terminally funding in actuarial lingo.
But basically they calculate the, you know, look at the eligible population for COLAs, which in this case is about 30, a little bit under 30,000 benefit recipients currently receiving something from NHRS, and then project out their life expectancies and how long they get this COLA and then create a present value cost if we had this much money in the bank today.
And there would be enough to pre-fund that benefit for the lifetime of the recipients.
So that's where the $79 million came from.
I think the last one in 2010 was about $50 million, but that was 11 years ago.
And the assumptions change and the populations change as well.
But that's where that number came from.
The 2019 COLA that took effect in Fiscal 20 wasn't pre-funded.
That one was funded through employer contribution.
So there was an increase to both the state employer contribution rates as well as the municipalities.
So this is a different approach to funding it.
So if the 79 million is approved, then that will fund COLAs for how long?
It would be a 1 and a half percent increase on the first thirty thousand for everyone who's retired you know before seven one of seventeen for as long as they'll live they'll get that increase you know will be in their monthly benefit for their lifetime okay well I sure didn't read that in here so so yeah the maximum it had one and a half percent on the first 30,000, the increase would be $450 a year.
So if you know somebody is as a 30,000 or more pension and it'll go up by $450 a year, you know, for as long as they live.
So that could be anywhere, you know, one to 50 years, but you know, that's, that's, that's how it works.
It's a permanent addition to the base benefit, if approved.
That's interesting.
Representative Leishman.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Nice to see you, Marty.
So if we were to provide just a one-year cost of living increase like we did in 2019, do you have like a off the envelope estimate what that would cost versus extending this out, as you said, one to 50 years?
There was a one-time payment.
I passed, I think, in 2018 and paid in fiscal 2019.
It was for a smaller pool of members.
That was a general fund appropriation as well.
If I recall, it was about $4 million, and it was one-time payment to about eight thousand eligible members I think they had to be retired like 20 years or something like that there was some parameters on that you know so it would depend on if you if you were going the one-time payment room you just have to like narrow down the universe of who was eligible and then we could tell you how many people that is, you know, and multiply that by the number.
It wouldn't be a recurring, you know, addition to the pension to bill one time, like an extra check.
Okay.
I kind of remember that.
Thanks, Marty.
Thanks, Mr.
Chairman.
Well, that's interesting.
Any other questions?
I would ask if you could, if you could figure out what that number is, and we can recess this and perhaps consider the one time on Monday.
I'll be back on Monday anyway, know if it's the same pool is affected by this bill which is somewhere between 29 and 30,000 benefits you multiply that by how much you want to give them as a one-time and you know it's it's a that's not an actual real can reverse engineer this one then yeah that's you know we wouldn't need to send out for that because it's just a math problem, X times X, where the compounding of the coal or all the other factors would require more analysis.
But, yeah.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
I mean, does that, the $79 million is compounded out already, including all the factors and compounding interest, yadda, yadda, yadda.
So we reverse engineer that to one time, one year.
I'm not sure, maybe when I was a senior in high school, I was sophisticated enough to narrow that down.
So it seems you have the expertise over there.
Could you just bring that figure with your money so our reverse engineering is completely accurate?
I just want to make sure you understand what you're asking.
Oh, the one-time.
The one-time one time period.
Example of how much would a one time cost for this pool.
Yes.
Okay, yeah.
Based on these factors.
Yes.
Thank you.
Does that make sense?
Yes, the issue is our general direction is to not open the budget up.
This is something normally would be considered during the budget cycle.
And so now that we have a fixed budget, what this is asking us to do is to revisit the budget.
And the general forces that be say, don't revisit the budget.
So if we're gonna revisit it, I don't think we're gonna revisit it at $79 million.
Though, if you could help us with a smaller revisit, we might have a shot, but I think that's where we are right now.
Is that acceptable to the committee?
Very much so, yeah.
Okay.
I'm very sure.
Yeah, so we will recess this work session until Monday morning at 10, along with all the other bills.
So we'll, and we're going to see you then anyway.
So thank you very much.
Thank you.
Anybody else wish to speak today.
Any other comments from the committee?
Well then we will recess until Monday the 14th at 10 o'clock.
And just so that everybody knows, the cameras are probably gonna stay on.
So I would highly recommend, if you're gonna have conversations, you better go out in the hall because the camera, the big eye is right there.
And we will reconvene at 2 o'clock.
And furthermore.
Yeah.
.
Yeah, come here.
Yeah.
10 o'clock Monday is the end.
1557 coming up too?
Yeah.
Yes.
Let me just make sure.
And this was 15, 1587.
Yeah.
And we don't know what time it's not at 10, but we don't know what time it's here.
time.
Thank you.